Justin Bieber has another run-in with  the law on Saturday the 23 year old  singer was pulled over by police at the  montage hotel in Beverly Hills  California  what do you Biebs had been cruising  around in his new mercedes-benz G wagon  prior to getting stopped check out this  photo of him chatting with a cop from  the driver's seat his tattoos clearly  visible according to TMZ police gave  Justin a citation for using his phone  while driving it's unclear whether he  was texting or talking he was reportedly  calm and cooperated with law enforcement  collecting his ticket and moving on  without further incident last month  Bieber instagrammed this throwback mug  shot from his 2014 arrest in Miami Beach  Florida riding hashtag jails no place to  be hashtag no fun hashtag never again  [Applause]  [Music]